getting ready to kick off the third
night of the rnc our special coverage
starts at the top of the hour
vice president mike pence headlining
tonight's event and one of the key
themes this week is cancel culture
covington teen nick sandman who was
smeared by the media calling them out
take a look
i learned what was happening to me had a
name
it was called being canceled as an
annulled
as in revoked as in made void
cancelled is what's happening to people
around this country who refuse to be
silenced by the far left
pretty big moment last night greg
yeah but you know the overarching
message here is that
the republican party is now the party of
individual freedom
if you look at the first two days anyway
you have the freedom to work the freedom
to live the freedom to be free in this
case from slander
and the freedom from violence and
intimidation so
we're getting this great contrast
individual freedom versus mob
the democratic party is the party of the
mob
uh brad he had a nice line when he said
the the full media
war machine revved up and didn't try to
ask me my side of the story wasn't
interested in the facts at all was a
real shot at just journalism in general
it's an amazing story he's getting the
last laugh
i love the fact that he wants to be a
lawyer and practice defamation law and
he can buy a lot of maga hats with that
settlement
dana that's just a great moment he just
slaps the maga hat right on at the end
and says have no fear
hey and you know that goes against dana
perino's pr rules that not putting on a
hat when you're doing an event but i
think that he pulled it off
very well i would also say it was quite
fun to see um
all the media have to be very very quiet
about his speech because
they have to yes juan uh we'll give you
the last word but just be careful what
you say
other than lockhart i guess i just hope
that i just hope that he's willing to
speak up
against the king of cancelled culture
the man who tried to
boycott goodyear harley-davidson
apple cnn the nfl macy's oh i
i think that's donald trump go nick go
speak out against him
i don't think you can cancel a fortune
company
you have to redefine it yeah yeah all
right